creativity is a compulsion  and i actually can't stop it and i  especially can't stop the train once  it's  gone i said on the last record highest  hope that i would stop after that one  and that's when i would settle down  and have a family and did you say that i  said that to friends i maybe didn't say  that to a journalist  no i did i publicly quit though so i did  say like i'm i'm gonna take a huge break  yeah and then when i came back from that  tour and i'd kind of  got through that record and how exposing  it was immediately  it's as if the songs wait and they wait  until i have  a breath  and then they all come flooding back in  being like yeah we need to take priority  in your life again so how do you feel  when that happens  i feel alive and then insane that i've  let it happen again